so we're told that G of X is equal to 2x
minus 1 over X plus 3
based on this pause the video and see if
you can figure out what the inverse of G
is G inverse of X what is that going to
be equal to
alright I'm assuming you've had a go at
it and just as a little bit of reminder
of what we're talking about we're
talking about inverse of functions are
inverses of functions if that's the
domain the set of all inputs that we can
input into G so that's the domain and if
we consider the range to be the set of
outputs so that is the range for a given
input so for a member of the domain X
the function G let me do it in that
color the function G will map it to a
point let me do G and yellow it will map
it to a member of the range so if this
is X this value right over here we would
consider to be G of X that's what the
function G does now the inverse function
goes the other way you start with a
member of the range and you go back to a
member of the domain that's what G
inverse does and so there's a couple of
ways to think about it if we were to set
if we were to say look let's just set Y
is equal to G of X so we could just call
that point Y as well so this says this
this this expression here let's just
okay if we have an X this is what we do
it we multiply two times did we subtract
one divided by X plus three and then
that tells us what the Associated G of X
where what the Associated Y is but what
if we're given the Y or the G of X how
do we get X well we could just solve for
X so let's do that if we said that Y is
equal to 2x 2x minus 1 over X plus 3
let's solve for x so that we know that
for any Y we get what X the
corresponding X will get so how do we do
that well we can multiply both sides
times X plus 3 so if we do that we're
going to get Y we're going to get Y
times X plus 3 X plus 3 is equal to
is equal to 2x minus one all I did is
multiply both sides times X plus three X
plus three and I multiplied X plus three
on that side as well the X plus three
cancels out with the X plus three and
then let's see let's see what we could
do now
well we could distribute the Y we could
distribute the Y and I'll switch now to
a different color because that's going
to get complicated if I keep trying to
separate the Y's in a different color so
we're going to get Y times X Y X plus
three y plus three Y is equal to two X
minus one and remember we are now trying
to solve for X so we could collect all
of the X terms on one side of this
equation and then all of the non x
involved terms on the other side so
let's get all of our X terms on the
left-hand side and all of our non X
terms on the right-hand side so I want
to get rid of this this doesn't involve
an X so let me subtract 3y here and so
I'll subtract 3y from this side minus 3y
and we want to get rid of this from the
right-hand side so minus 2x so we could
put it right over here minus 2x and so
we are going to get let me scroll down a
little bit so whoops sorry for that so
this is going to be YX minus 2x is going
to be Y minus 2 times X these cancel out
which is what their goal is equal to 2x
minus 2x those cancel out which was the
goal and then you have 1 minus 3 y 1
minus 3y and now to solve for X you just
divide both sides by Y minus 2 y minus 2
and we're going to get X is equal to 1
minus 3y over Y minus 2 so one way you
could think about it is you could say
well X is equal to this this expression
is equal to the inverse function as a
function of Y you give me a why you give
me a y that's sitting in this range I
can input it into this this function
definition here and I can give you the
corresponding
I can give you the corresponding X now
we didn't ask for G inverse of Y we
asked for G inverse of X but the
important thing to remember is this
variable that we use inside of the
variable that we use inside of functions
right over here this there's their
chosen somewhat arbitrarily they just
say okay I'm going to call the input Y
and if you're going to call the input Y
well this is how I would give you the
output but we could call the input a and
then would be 1 minus 3a over a minus 2
or we could even call the input so let
me make this clear
so we have G inverse of Y actually since
I did it in blue up here let me write
that in blue as well so if we did if we
did G inverse G inverse of Y I'm just
rewriting what we already have is equal
to 1 minus 3y over Y minus 2 it's this
choice of variable is arbitrary we could
say G inverse of of smiley face of
smiley face is equal to 1 minus 3 times
smiley face three times smiley face over
smiley face minus 2 or if we wanted to
in terms of if we want to call the input
X we would just write G inverse of X is
equal to 1 minus 3x over X minus 2 and
we'd be done now I really want to point
out you might say well this is this is
confusing because now we're calling the
input to this X well you know we
normally associate Y with the variables
of the Rays that's true but you have to
remember these these variables are just
and they're just labels that we we apply
to things so that we can keep track of
them but the they're just what we call
the input so we could call the input
into the inverse function we call it X
smiley face Y you know ABCD whatever we
want so they wanted it in terms of G
inverse of X so we're going to define
the input as X whatever we input into it
as X and so this is going to be the
expression that that map's that map's
back now another way that you could have
done this because if you think about
what just happened here if we said now
that Y is equal to G inverse we've
essentially swapped the x and y variable
so one way to solve these is you can
start where we started right over there
and then you swap the X's in the Y's
which is essentially what we did at the
last step the way I did it and then you
solve for y after the swap and you would
get to this same result and you could
say Y is equal to G inverse so I
encourage you to try either way